the race to find solutions during this
pandemic has led to a new age of
innovation that includes products meant
to help keep us safe from possibly risky
things like touching our faces or door
handles Charlie d'Agata reports on some
of the inventions that could eventually
become part of our lives people touch
their faces all the time all the time he
put such a face 23 times per hour
you know it's an unconscious behavior
that just happens stopping it from just
happening is what Seattle based designer
Justin earth had in mind with his
vibrating bracelet reducing the risk of
the corona virus entering the body
through vulnerable points so you you
basically calibrate this is when I touch
my eyes doesn't touch my nose doesn't
touch my mouth that's when you do that
in the future
it'll then vibrate the global pandemic
and the challenges of a post lockdown
world have already inspired a slew of
ideas like dividing screens in
restaurants plexiglass cubicles for the
beach and mobile barriers on car
assembly lines
how about a Chinese designed antivirus
bodysuit or this thermal imaging smart
helmet recently deployed in Dubai
straight out of Robocop on the hunt for
people running a temperature a symptom
of CO vid 19 not all inventions need to
be so eye-catching in the world we now
live in every surface is a potential
health hazard especially door handles
one British inventor came up with this
he's called it the hygiene hook pretty
simple concept really works like this
and like this and the idea was to make
the lives of health workers easier they
change the gloves every time they're
gonna get a cup of coffee just maneuver
around the hospital
inventors Steve Brooks has already
donated hundreds to hospital workers are
we seeing new age of innovation now yes
an age not seen since the last truly
global period of upheaval to win this
fight we have undertaken the greatest
national mobilization since World War
two world war ii saw an explosion of
inventions and innovations castelo upon
Hut like long-range guided missiles
which helped launch the era of space
exploration and the jet engine which
revolutionized commercial aviation and
radar revealed to the world after years
of secrecy which came of age in the
early 1940s but that period also
introduced the modern ballpoint pen and
super glue everyday objects you'd find
in your home today and home is exactly
where just in its idea started currently
because for personal reasons my father
is in his late 60s and she has an
autoimmune disease that makes them
immune to compromise we wanted to jump
to action and protect people like my dad
and all our families around the world
that are in that situation sometimes
complicated situations call for simple
solutions one day we may wonder how we
lived without them
for CBS this morning Charlie d'Agata
London really interesting stuff it is
fascinating how many times we touch our
face even in an hour
unconsciously Tony I like the idea of
what the hygiene hook he calls it
because the the door opening thing is a
constant problem yeah necessity it
really is the mother of invention and a
couple things that weren't mentioned in
that piece but we're also inventions
from prior periods when innovation was
necessary the watch the trench coat the
weather forecast itself came out of
military efforts in World War two and I
do like that watch preventing you from
touching your face it certainly beats my
idea the kind of cone that dogs wear to
prevent themselves from licking after
surgery it's not a good look prevents me
from drinking my coffee after the show
now that's a really great piece yeah